menschen helfen gutes tun und
zusammenhalten jetzt gerade in diesen
schweren zeiten von corona das ist auch
thema heute in nrw hier haben sich unter
dem motto einen funken hoffnung bauern
getroffen sie sind auf die straße
gegangen aber mit ihren 50 weihnachts
traktoren wir sehen das jetzt hier auch
schon im bild sieht super aus
gemeinsam wurden krankenhäuser
angefahren oder auch altenheime um
wirklich schöne weihnachtslieder
gemeinsam laut hören zu können und um
jahr ein funken hoffnung zu schenken
das ist eine super schöne idee und mein
kollege michael engelberg er ist vor ort
im münsterland unterwegs ich sehe auch
die traktoren hinter der erzähl uns wie
kommt die aktion an und was wünschen
sich denn die bauern das ist im kreis
steinfurt im münsterland geschehen mit
50 traktoren geschmückt sind
es geht darum dass die
landwirtschaftliche verbindung
landschaft verbindung den kindern und
alle die die hilfe brauchen auch ein
funken ins gesicht zaubern wollte ist
natürlich dass krankenhäuser und
altenheime kinderstationen gerade sehr
sehr schwierig sind dass man die kinder
besuchen kann landwirten geht es gerade
nicht so richtig gut dennoch wollen sie
den kindern zeigen dass man auch für sie
da sind
und deshalb haben
landwirte ganz viele trecker geschmückt
ein nikolaus ist dabei sie haben spenden
gesammelt für die kinder damit spielzeug
gesammelt wurde und hier ist auch der
nikolaus den julian erhardt uns nicht
weil der bericht darauf aufpassen muss
dass er gleich weiter fahren muss und
man muss sagen den kindern kommt das
ganz gut an wenn man gerade am
mathias-spital eine kinderklinik da
haben die kinder schon den ganzen
nachmittag eine scheibe gestanden haben
haben den leuten zu geworden da geht es
nämlich darum ein zeichen zu setzen sie
fand es wirklich sehr schön dass
landwirte sich für sie ja bereit gemacht
haben um ihnen ein kleines lächeln aufs
gesicht zu zaubern und ihr seht hier ist
richtig was los
die landwirte haben sich nicht leisten
haben die rezeptoren die gesagt schön
geschmückt und bei der belegschaft bei
den heimen und bei den kindern kommt die
situation und die ganze aktion sehr gut
an
wir sind bild und wir liefert dir deine
news auf youtube zum nächsten video
kommst du hier
und vergiss bitte nicht unseren kanal zu
abonnieren